can I say one thing to you what brings
you to Miami I have two plantation
master poisons don't word on the ground
that kills you a spurts
[Music]
well there will be a season two we start
filming September 5th all these people
are in it and it's gonna be great it's
gonna write this down now our supposed
to say well we as the audience know that
David's dad is the infamous Professor X
from the x-men in comics what are the
chances that we could be getting him in
season 2 well I think we want we
definitely want to address that you know
I mean it's it's normal when you when
you learned here adopted to want to know
who your real family is he doesn't yet
know the identity and so I think it'll
be the process to get there it's quite a
little bit explaining that yeah
you've dad is Professor X I think right
yes then you're like what is the X stand
for yeah so yeah right so yeah we're on
that path definitely well season 1 was
sort of the fight with the enemy within
now with the enemies without and and yet
I think I still want to try to resist
this you know every conflict to solve
through warfare idea and still continue
to explore the the ideas of mental
illness that we race in the first season
it's not just a gimmick to get us into a
superhero show so you know I think I
think David will find himself perhaps
feeling like the same man in an insane
world as opposed to the insane man
oh by the way that's gonna happen you
know he's on a journey and and you know
now that I think we've settled is this
in his head or is this real I think he's
got to figure out you know which side of
the fight he wants to be on and and and
you know can can we all get along or you
know and people who are different get
along with the people who are normal so
you know I think there's a lot of
challenges coming up for him hey
everybody we got our first look at
Legion season two it's premiering in
April we don't have a firm premiere date
but of course I'll do episode videos
like I did for season one so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get everything they directly address
Professor X they're like oh yeah we're
building towards that reveal Professor X
in Deadpool it's not for me to say oh
it's huge for you that would be so
technically
Patrick sir Patrick yes my father I mean
yes did you know that david hauless
father in the Marvel Universe is huge so
essentially I've got a job offer this is
massive they give you a pretty good idea
of what the main conflict of the season
is going to be like it used to be David
versus his own mind like he was trying
to figure out whether or not he was
going crazy now that they figured it out
it's more about David being the sane man
in a crazy world so like everybody else
is gonna be going bonkers they did say
that would be a pretty big time jump so
that they could tell stories in the same
way that they told them during season
one like you could never quite tell what
time period things were taking place
during so they wanted to maintain that
aspect of disorientation where like
things feel like they're going crazy but
remember David is the same one he knows
about his powers so he just has to
decide which side of the line he's gonna
fall on like the whole idea behind
division 3 is that it's sort of like a
government-backed
Trask industries so like they try to
hunt mutants down capture them study
them turn them into their lap dogs
that's kind of a consistent theme across
all
x-men stories it'll be interesting to
see how they address that if they ever
cross them over with the Avengers
because the Avengers are celebrated in
their universe they're like oh wow these
heroes are gonna save us like the Battle
of New York they really saved our asses
but in the world of the x-men everybody
gets treated like trash so we'll see how
they figure that out Kevin Feige also
did address that recently he said that
he's had absolutely no conversations
with anybody at Disney about getting to
use x-men characters he's like that's
way above my pay grade they still gotta
figure out that deal he says that
they've announced all their movies
through 2019 so none of the Marvel phase
three phase four movies are gonna change
at least until 2020 after that like he
left room like okay we might change our
slate after that depending on what goes
down I don't know how that would affect
the TV shows because there's a lot of
Marvel TV shows then there's a lot of
x-men based Marvel TV shows and if you
can cross that over and use any
characters that you want then anything
could be up for grabs so I don't think
the TV shows are gonna be affected too
much by this they've already shot the
entire season it's ten episodes long
instead of eight episodes like season
one so pretty much the entire main cast
like they say is coming back but now the
shadow king is inhabiting Oliver's mind
who's also a powerful telepath so he's
going to be the effective big bat but
they've also cast another actor to play
the Shadow King in what seems like it's
going to be flashback scenes like we'll
probably learn more about his history
this is the actor who's going to be
playing him but again Aubrey Plaza is
playing Ville any character in
present-day
who's inhabiting Oliver's mind when we
see this character it will probably just
be for those flashback scenes but in the
way that they play was really unreliable
narration and make it seem like
everybody's going crazy they could wind
up doing just about everything but this
actor here is what the Shadow King
looked like before Professor X battled
him and trapped him in the astral plane
and he started to look like this like
the really gross dude from season one so
again circling back around to Professor
X we got that big explainer last year
they did the chalkboard explainer to say
how the shadow king got trapped in the
astral plane and he was starting to
figure out oh you know this is my father
but they didn't actually save Professor
X you just saw a version of the
wheelchair so he kind of understands who
his father is but they haven't made it
explicit yet in
like I said they're very ambiguous about
what the year is so we don't know how
many adventures the x-men have had if
this is set during the future of their
timeline if this is sometime in the past
the funny thing they do just to fit with
the theme of everything being crazy in
the series is that they have a mixture
of really old timey technology from like
the 60s and 70s but then they also have
really advanced series style AI so it's
almost like everybody has iPhones but
it's still the 1960s but again the
series is premiering in April probably
around the same time as Westworld season
2 but HBO and FX haven't given firm
dates for either of those series so I'm
guessing sometime early to mid April but
if you haven't seen my Game of Thrones
explainer for when Game of Thrones
season 8 has to premiere in order to be
eligible for Emmys you actually have to
get a couple episodes out by a certain
time so the bare minimum is the third
week in April so the series will not
premiere after the third week in April
so no worries about that I'll do another
video when they release another trailer
and they give affirm premiere date
that's probably what will happen when we
see more footage like this is the exact
date that we're gonna see episodes but
post all your questions in the comments
below I didn't really address it but I
love Patrick Stewart joking about
popping up during the Deadpool sequel
it's not for me to say that interview
was actually done before they shot the
Deadpool sequel so who knows he might
have a cameo I'm not expecting it but it
would be pretty funny if he did the
reminder about that because we have
Super Bowl trailers coming this weekend
they've said that we're probably not
gonna get a Deadpool - Super Bowl
trailer but they will attach one to the
Black Panther movie which isn't out for
about another two weeks so sometime in
the next two weeks there will be a new
Deadpool - trailer but don't expect one
during the Superbowl but probably Star
Wars Han Solo maybe Avengers infinity
war new black panther so whatever is
happening I will totally do a video for
it this weekend but there is actual
black panther that I'll be posting next
today in a couple hours so while you
wait for that if you haven't seen any of
them here's all my Legion season 1
videos and you can click here for brand
new Avengers infinity war thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]